okay hi everyone
welcome to
another wolfram language design review
part of our incremental language design
series
and we have a variety of topics let us
start with the same as and replace at
documentation
okay
let's see
these are two different functions that
came out of well from function
repository functions we looked at
previously they both have
implementations and prototype builds and
we just wanted to finalize and make sure
everything looks good here
well does that does the implementation
of
replace that address my concerns about
the extended syntax
yeah so we have the same syntax support
in
uh replace that that we added into map
at
in terms of the
handling of multiple positions was the
question i'm guessing right
same as has the bizarre feature that it
is um
sub-commutative so to speak
for what it's worth
so what
yeah i think this is okay
um
that's interesting
same cue
what does that mean wait a minute why is
that right
why is what right
this this um
multi thing
here i mean same q is their args what
else would you expect same as to do
yeah
i mean the only possible point of
disagreement is maybe the y's should
come before the x's in the same cube but
other than that i i don't see how
there's anything controversial here
is there any time when the order matters
like does it i guess maybe for some
performance things it could
theoretically matter but
it can matter if you have um
you know
arbitrary precision while machine at
least machine precision if you have an
exact numbers because like the bits
might be close enough that they're sort
of all close to each other but like the
last one is not
you know sufficiently close to the first
but oh i see it it only does pairwise
checking when you give it there are
things right
i see
i personally have no problem with the
second bracket the first bracket feels a
bit strange because you could just you
could
know that it's going to return false
always without the second bracket
and i can imagine that this is not going
to be converted into false
function
right
right
right as it currently stands there is no
down code associated with same as
right even though as jose says
right same as
x y applied to anything will be false
now if the idea of that is a sort of a
bit of a performance thing then it's it
just means it's going to have to run
same q on x the x's
twice you know once in the down code
once in the the sub code
right yeah i mean we could right i mean
we could
uh
yeah i don't think there's a there's a
good way to do this i mean i suppose you
could make the argument that same as
bracket bracket could evaluate the same
q because that really is
uh
i think my argument is that the first
bracket should have just one element and
the second any number
i kind of agree
i see
i kind of agree
and by the way i don't understand what
this line means
right it means the right it means what i
just said so same as of the bracket you
know now open bracket x y
is equivalent to bracket of x y
now if we're going to say that same as
can only can only ever be one argument
and that same as of bracket bracket
should be an error message
and same as a of two two more guys
should be an
error message than
you know
i'm okay with that i guess what i think
what did we do with equal two i guess
that's that's the question so what does
equal two of bracket bracket do yeah
equal two does require one argument
okay
so what does that evaluate to
uh to itself with the message okay
right and does equal two of what one
bracket
you know two comma three work
so even though it's documented as
oh well that's a very
unfortunate behavior suspicious
um
this could be extended right yes right i
mean i uh right i mean to me right i i
i think that in the second set of
brackets it should be var arg just like
equal is
but i think
i i take no position uh
on whether the first argue is the first
set of brackets should be far arg or not
and i'm perfectly okay with it being
restricted to one argument
i think that's the defensive design that
we should adopt right now
okay yeah i can probably make the
changes to equal to to have our args in
the second set of brackets but we'll use
that as the template for same as then
okay replace that
oh boy this looks more complicated
what is replace
last time what was the difference
between replace that and map at a
replace
that replace that doesn't depend on the
valuation
i see i see right so right so replace it
and replace that inside of a hold and it
will it'll actually do the replacement
as opposed to just inserting a replace
operator form right
on on a certain level if we had
right if we had the
you know immediate evaluate we've talked
about we wouldn't really need replace
that other than possibly a syntactic
sugar
um
murph shot seems useful
i mean
i see so
given so we can have a span here as well
presumably
and a span means take each individual
place
i mean so if i say
right so so the way we dealt with this
on
um
extract right is we basically said you
know there
you have position specs and then you
have extended position specs which are
basically
a
a part spec wrapped in the list
um
i mean you can you can look at the notes
for
for x uh
extract if you want to see exactly how
we
stated that there
[Music]
right an individual position
specification pause can also be of the
more general form list part one
so the third note there
okay
this is useful this is useful just
replace that
um okay
anything more to discuss about it
uh
nope i think that one in particular is
in good shape we'll make the changes to
same as uh and equal to okay
the next point was just we had a
discussion about ancestor tree and
treetop in a previous meeting and wanted
to circle back to the names and just
make sure we were
all on the same page there
i don't like ancestry
i mean i'm not even sure i like either
of these let's just discuss what they
are again
can i um
by the way what why is there that delay
on first use is that a loading thing
i think so
that
i i think it's self-drawing
is ian here
yeah okay
can you say what that delay is
i'm i'm assuming jose is right
can we look okay when you scroll down
and graph it you know before it shows
the graphic it stops
feel it again
you're just talking about the delay of
when you scroll down and before it shows
you the graphic of the tree it pauses
the moment no no i'm talking about the
fact when i typed 9 or 3 of 30 it took a
while
oh where should i try it again i'm sure
it's blindingly fast
yeah
so my only point is
can we at least look at the the loading
to just see if there's anything we can
optimize there
okay
okay
is is
it being loaded in any way differently
from other mx files
it shouldn't be it's it's appear it's
now a pure startup thing
i mean it does
depend on some number of things right so
maybe autoloading more than one mx file
which is probably investigated
um
okay is this not yet in there
answers tree and tree top
yeah correct
uh treetop i have a branch open but it's
not in the prototype build and there
hasn't been approaches there's so many
jokes about branches and trees
yeah yeah unfortunate for i yeah i've
opened an re ticket why there hasn't
been a new prototype built since tuesday
so they're looking at that now so even
if you had added it it wouldn't be in
in stephen's build yet
okay
all right
gives the top of the tree
you don't want to say up to level n you
need to say down to level n
if it's the top of the tree
or just to level n it's totally
confusing
there's a breakdown in terminology also
because normally the top of the tree is
where all the leaves are but you know
right
right
it's it's really like tree roots or tree
yeah tree trunk
so
the reason
that we had up to was because it has up
to like behavior
okay look yeah that's and that's that's
not a good reason in this case okay what
should we call this so let's see what it
does again
tree shrub
and tree take
is already taken for something else
no
it's not taken
correct
right although
tree roots are pretty it's a pretty
common notion and terminology and
computer science
probably should not
like you know reverse it or anything
well but isn't the roots is like the
root is the the single top one is there
a name for like the intermediate ones or
it's not a leaf and it's not the root
sometimes the term node is used
both for intermediate and and atoms what
about calling it root tree
what so
i guess the the thing is
the operation is going up to a level
and the name isn't communicating
anything about that we're just saying
what about giving a true like the result
is a tree and trees have a root
it's just a complete coincidence right
what about calling it a root tree
every tree has roots and and and or has
a root like i know that
but there's just the tree
you know
it's just the root part of the tree
but the root part of the tree is the
single vertex at the top i know it's why
it's called a root tree rather than just
the root
thinking about it as like this this
right this upper part of the tree is
like a root and then there's
upper no we're talking about this is the
tree root we all agree that's the tree
root
yes even though botanically it's at the
top
right so so we're making the distinction
between tree root and root tree
i'm starting to like etai's idea of a
trunk
because that's what we're capturing it's
not the trunk it's not the trunk it's
it's the part of the tree it is the root
tree it is the part of the tree hanging
from the root that only goes to a
certain level
i mean other than the fact that if we
had something called tree take we'd need
to also make some sense of negative and
and spans
well
negative works
you get i don't think spans
you're going to get disconnected sub
trees if you go from the top
no so negative just means go down to the
negative level you're still always going
for from the top
oh well then we definitely don't i don't
think we want to call that take right no
it doesn't take a take spec so you know
i'm sorry i keep on pushing root tree
because i think it's a pretty good name
it's the tree
it's the root
section of this tree
i think that the problem is that root
just you know
root is just a has a very strong and
particular meaning and the connection to
this concept is extremely tenuous but
root tree comma one but it isn't just
the root it's the i mean okay
can i just say if you do comma infinity
it's just the whole tree like i know
what you're describing it's from the
root down that's just describing a tree
i know i know i know i know it's just
all good let me understand what ancestor
tree is
okay just so i understand what
that's the
ancestor tree of a given node
same thing but with a position spec
instead of a level
uh i was i was expecting things like
you know second cousin once removed in
ancestor tree and i don't see it yeah
that that will be supported symbolically
in the tree relative
oh yeah i don't understand ancestry so
you're saying in one case it's down to a
certain level
in the other case it is everything that
you need
that is in the in the you know the the
nose that had to exist to get to this
node
is that correct i mean does it include
position or list of positions
yeah
so so if you get a single same operation
just gives you a path tree that tells
you how to get to the root which is
algorithmically i think super useful
like if you imagine so it's like the
minimal that the minimal dag right yeah
we're going to be technical right it's
the minimal dag that includes the
specified elements yes
okay what about initial tree
i like it
for what
for what's currently called
tree
for a treetop
i don't know i don't that doesn't i
don't buy that because it's the the
notion of time
is yet a different issue
maybe it's a little too botanical but
we're also
thinking about what we're doing to pull
the tree back we're effectively pruning
the tree
oh pruning is what everything's safe yes
entertaining but not well that's a
that's a problem with ancestor tree is
it it's in the tree extract tree delete
family that's usually tree action
i suggest an initial tree because the
notion of an initial
segment is also common in computer
science yeah but i understand right i
don't understand why you guys so hate
root tree
i i don't actually hate it i i just
think it might not be optimal
okay but i mean what i like about it is
that it is
well okay i i'm sorry i still want to
get back to this ancestor tree thing
because really we've got to have these
two cases one is
you are finding the
predecessor tree
of a given node
and the other is
you're finding up to a certain level
down the tree
right those are the two cases as i
understand it
yes
yep
and i would say i don't you know i'm
definitely not in the camp that hates
root tree but i
you know i don't disregard the concern
that it sounds too similar that it
evokes the root of the tree which is a
singular node i know but root three
comma one is the singular node right no
commas comma zero
okay
i mean root tree with one argument could
be
um
is there one just as a tree extract of a
tree comma one or zero or something is
the root i mean
so what
the
root node is the empty list for a
position spec remind me what tree level
does
it gives a list of the sub trees on the
given levels
same as level
okay
if we use root tree for the thing that
goes from the root to a given level
what about the possibility of root tree
and predecessor tree
predecessor tree for ancestor tree
well well
i
think ancestor is clearer than
predecessor
really i i was i was going to go in in
the other way but maybe that's you know
working on gravity uh
you know coming from the garage school
well okay but ancestor tree the problem
is we've got so much confusion with
genealogical trees which are different
from these
well no so it in a genealogical tree
it's actually a dag but in order to have
the family relationships you're
referring to a tree
within that dag
yeah
so
tree relative is exactly the
story of genealogical relationships and
it
kind of depends on the type of family i
wouldn't assume it's always a tree
just saying
well so if you include everybody it's
definitely not a tree
and so you always have to
choose a sub-tree of the dag in order to
speak about family relationships
there is however a partial order for our
species
yes
the
begat word works
um
okay
all right so what are we going to do
here so we've got one case
is making the
prune subtree that just gets to a given
particular position or collection or the
union tree of those positions
and we've got another case
that just goes to a certain level
level tree
that's horrifying is it is it horrifying
because that's what it is it's a tree
down to a certain level
say that again
what's that
it's not horrifying
i like it it's a bit annoying that
there's tree level and level three then
yeah
that would be genuinely confusing so
that's a problem
well but don't they do they do uh
complementary things right level what is
it
the existing one tree level gives you
everything below level whatever and
level tree gives you everything above
level whatever
yeah no no people would not remember
that it's like having random sample and
random choice only worse
no i mean yes yeah it's it's
right but they are very related but i
agree that it's just like the the
ordering of the words
means nothing
this is arbitrary okay how about
i mean how about admitting that they're
the same thing and basically
trying to have two names that are you
know one is level above one is level
below or something
well
i don't think they're really the same
thing right tree level gives you a list
of subtrees at that that start at that
level and go down to the leaves
yes right
so
and right then you can give right you
can give a range of specs right so if
you give three to five
right you'll get a tree that starts with
seven
or 15 however it is that we count
and goes down and then you know a tree
that starts at 24 and a tree that starts
at three and a three that starts at nine
and
i i know right one one always gives you
one and the other gives you the number
of nodes that live at that level which
so i i'm it's not clear to me that they
really are the same thing or
complementary things right
whereas i think ancestor tree and tree
extracts are more genuinely like dual to
each other
what does tree extract do again it goes
it makes the sub tree from a given
element
each position
you get a sub tree
you basically tell it if you start at
the root and then you you you know you
tell it go left now go right now go left
now go right you know what do you get
yeah as a sub tree going on from there
yep yeah
and this is what you get going
getting how you got there
right
[Music]
what the heck should that be called
i think the most common use is going to
be something like you know
imagine you're you've implemented
dijkstra's algorithm and you have a tree
of you know the things that you hit and
now you want to and you reach your
destination now you want to know what
how did it take to get here and you want
to look at all of your ancestors
or it's a theorem proving-ish thing
where you've got you've enumerated all
these cases and you want to know what
the path was what's the proof sure
would origin tree be too generic
pest light cone tree
so it always goes all the way to the
root though right
right yeah
it doesn't need to why would it need to
why why wouldn't it be able to go from
level such and such to
well what could you not in case it could
give a list i guess
what is tree level
tree level is
like level only for trees right i mean
it really is
right just like level gives you the this
is it's just it's just wait a minute
tree level doesn't extract the tree it's
tree extract comma tree level right
you can do tree level of tree comma
level spec same as level oh god right
tree level is just you know tree level
of expression tree of blah we should do
basically the same exact thing as
level of
blah
yes
but the one argument form of a pure
level spec
which occurs here
yeah you can use these operator forms in
position specs
so why
i'm sorry go ahead
no on that origin tree i was wondering
what about tree to node or something
like that
do we call them notes
in various places we've
called them nodes
usually when we want to convey like just
this one position and nothing
connected to it
like the node in the graph
and what about the relation with three
delete because intriguing you also
specify a number of positions and you
delete what is
from that position
well here you keep up to that position
so so there is a difference in the node
you are specifying plus the branches
that you that you are not specifying
so could this be considered a variant of
tree delete
i think so
what's a variant of tree delete ancestor
tree like
going back to nick's suggestion of tree
prune it's like it's like tree delete
except tree delete deletes downwards
this is super confusing this is like
delete everything other than what i
specified
what do we call the nodes here
do we have a name for them
tree element or nodes
tree two element
no that sounds like it's converting um
well the other problem is that sometimes
our element sort of sounds like atom
like you're at the very end of you know
of the tree
uh
let me see
we're a bit stuck here i don't like
treetop and ancestor tree i really don't
make it
so one of them is
so why why why did is the consensus that
we don't like predecessor tree and and
if so why
actually i kind of like that one
predecessor tree
i think it's i think it's pretty decent
except it's always a path tree
except if there are multiple things it
might be a tree otherwise it's a path
tree
right
but it's always going to be a tree data
structure
yeah i think answers to sheets
because it's a tree
you're going to get a tree data
structure out
the process of path i would expect to
get a list of nodes
list of elements
i also briefly thought about sourcetree
but that's also a
no forget so let's be confused
now how would i get the list of tree
elements out of that
i've got predecessor tree i've got a
it's a path tree what how do i get those
developments
tree level of that coma all
wow not the best thing i mean i
understand
tree level really no no no that's not
giving me the elements it's going to
give me a bunch of of singleton trees
isn't it what do you want you're running
the data in the tree yes i want all the
data i want in it'd be tree level of
level level arrow data
block
remember this is a very general sort of
thing it happens that this tree is just
a bunch of connected
segments without branches but no i
understand branches you've got
traversals
all right look i think predecessor tree
is the right name for that
in the in the documentation i commonly
use the phrases or the terms ancestors
and descendants and i think those would
be
equivalent to predecessors and
successors
but successors just sounds very strange
look i think ancestry just has the
problem of genealogical trees
which this isn't
i think it is
what do other people think about this i
just think it it you know every time i
think about it it gets confusing this is
the function you'll type in things like
ancestry of tree comma
tree relative uncles
yeah i mean i think i think it is the
ancestors right i mean
you think it's not just relatives it is
specifically the ancestors
all right
okay well what about treetop then
it's the treetop was the leaves i i
think tree top is very confusing
i agree with that
well then that will be root tree
potentially
the tree's starting to leak
it's not the trunk
it's not the trunk i mean look at this
what is
it's the trunk in the branches it's
everything but the leaves
trunk and branches is not trunk
i mean i'm looking at a tree it's
everything but the leaves right well
everything but a certain level what does
what does trunk
mean to you steven
it means the main single
so like in the top picture where you
have a part where there's no branching
for a while and then branching starts
well there's the trunk and i mean i
don't know i don't know which which this
this tree
is not a very chunky tree i mean you
know a botanical tree
is more
you know it's more obviously has a trunk
and branch i feel like when a tree
branch i'm looking at a tree right now
that you know has two trunks so i i
don't know but
most trees have one trunk in the first
approximation
um
i was literally just going through the
the
live stream about the section of nks
about these things
i think
you said initial tree
either that or tree initial i'm not
actually
sure which is the better order
i still don't understand why you guys so
hate root tree
because it's the it's the root of this
tree
it's the root area the root of the tree
what's that it's it's just an arbitrary
tree sharing the same root as the
original tree i know but it's it's the
root region of the tree
unlike some of these
i feel like that would be like having i
mean two problems the first is that we
we might already have but like we can
imagine having a function called tree
root which gives you the actual root
also i think tree data is basically that
function like if you say tree data of a
tree it gives you the data at the root
of the tree no that's not the same so
actually how about maybe maybe one
solution would be to have okay maybe
here's one way in which
root tree or tree root could actually
work would be if we had a function tree
root you give it a tree and it returns
the root and then optionally you know
you give it some you know second
arguments where it gives you the
neighborhood of the root
yeah well right but the function the
function's first usage though is tree
root it doesn't give you a tree it gives
you the root well
the problem is that we don't have a
representation for nodes
we have a perfect good if root tree
returns a tree it just happens to be a
singleton tree
that is just the roots i see
i can just fill the the leaves with null
or an empty list or whatever
so that's what we do
right
i like that
and then the second argument tells you
how many levels it is
and most of the time you would end up
with um i mean you know in other words
would be zero but you could say two
yes
yes i'm sorry i i i've gotten lost what
is the current proposal
okay root tree
of two arguments returns exactly what we
have here
for you know with the n as the second
argument
root tree of one argument returns the
same thing with n equals zero in other
words it returns the singleton top
element but it returns it as a tree not
just its payload
now but one question is i mean i would
argue maybe it should be called tree
root because the framing could be that
this is a function that returns the root
and it happens to have some extra
functionality i worry that people will
think that that means it returns the
payload of the route
i think we should just document this in
comparison with tree data
so they know to use tree data for that
yeah i know but i think if it's root
tree it makes it clear on its on its
name that it is returning a tree
well in some sense the root tree
to me suggests that you're talking about
the
the whole tree the tree itself
why instead of just the root of the tree
because
that
it's the tree that's at the root
um yeah like i would imagine root tree
would be a function if we had forests
root tree would be the function give it
the root and it gives you the tree under
it
and by the way
do we effectively have forests are lists
of trees effectively forests yeah
are those actually supported by
functions though as forests like by tree
functions
we don't currently have any tree
functions that need lists of trees
do they take this thing on trees are
they capable of taking lists of trees
i mean i would say we convert we assume
that forests are
connected by some node
and then converted into a single tree
i see
i unfortunately have to leave even
though we've got a lot of very
interesting and juicy things to discuss
here
um uh
perhaps we can have a part two
sooner or later
there's a bunch of important things here
um
drat i really wanted to we got to
continue with this particular thing
um
yeah so let's see whether we can get
this scheduled soon
okay yeah we'll talk to scheduling
okay
thanks guys sorry i have to run um
uh actually hold on one second let me
just determine um
yeah i think the the
um
um
okay
all right